[Music]
what if we get to know the probability
of us falling a prey to a particular
disorder in advance what if we can
predict serious disorders like cancer
using simple medical testing is that
possible or is it just fiction
well no it's already being done with the
concept of genetic testing or the
technique in which our genes or
chromosomes are tested help us here so
what are pros Ohm's we've always come
across the same humans have 23 pairs of
chromosomes but what are they made up of
and where are they actually located in
the cell let's try and answer all of
these queries in this session here B has
this simple cell as an example can you
see the thread-like structures here in
the nucleus these threads are called
chromatids
they are usually tangled in this fashion
when present in a regular active cell
but what if the cell has to undergo
division is it possible to divide the
single cell into two equal halves with
such a tangled bundle of threads of
course not imagine we have these
different colored threads tangled
together if we were to separate them
then what should be the first thing we
should do
we will first separate each thread and
then make separate bunches in a similar
way even the cells separate these
chromatid threads this process is aided
by condensation of threads it means
these chromatid material will gradually
start coiling like a telephone wire as a
result the threads will gain structures
like these are we familiar with this
kind of a structure have you come across
it before that's correct it is the
structure of a typical chromosome what
are chromosomes well we get into their
details in the upcoming sessions for now
need to get a basic idea about them so
we have this cell with threads sorted in
this classical chromosome structure this
structure is seen only when the cell is
in the process of division so can we say
that both chromatids and chromosomes are
the same yes they are the different
names are for the different structures
now the next question is what are these
threats or chromosomes to be precise
made up of if we zoom into the structure
of this chromosome we find small
segments like these that make up the
complete structure these functional
segments are nothing but genes she can
be saved at chromosomes are made up of
genes absolutely
all these segments make up the whole
structure now let me ask you one more
interesting question do you think the
genes will also be made up of something
will there be units that make up these
segments if your answer is yes then
you're absolutely right genes are also
made up of some units if we zoom inside
this gene segment then we find large
molecules like these that make up the
segments these large molecules are
macromolecules to be precise our DNA
molecules this is not a new term for us
we are quite familiar with the term DNA
as it's very commonly used these days
but what exactly are these DNA molecules
well this single large molecule is
composed of three units and what units
are these let's reserve this explanation
for our upcoming videos for now all we
need to know is that DNA is made up of
these units now to quickly review what
we learnt let me remove the text from
the screen these three combine to give
us a single molecule and many such DNA
molecules form long chains what is a
sequence of
DNA molecules called that's right it's
called a gene so technically segments of
DNA molecules which form functional
units are called
genes and many genes come together to
form thread-like structures called
chromosomes chromosome is the classical
structure obtained only during cell
division when the cell is not in the
dividing phase the genetic material is
present in the form of tangled threads
called chromatids so this is the basic
idea of the genetic materials in
ourselves which we needed to understand
in order to look at the loss in genetics
let's get introduced to the laws and
genetics put forth by Gregor Mendel in
the next part
[Music]
you